all right folks before we get started i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by aspire
more specifically some
classic star wars games they have going
on sale right now
those games will be jedi knight jedi
academy jedi knight 2 jedi outcast and
star wars episode 1
racer and they're 50 off on nintendo
switch and xbox one 50
off on playstation 4 with playstation
plus 40 without on playstation 4 the
sale goes on until january 19th
xbox one and nintendo switch goes on
until january 21st so strike while the
iron's hot click the link below go to
aspire.com
star wars relive some great star wars
games episode one razer you kidding me
had a lot of fun with that game back in
the day on n64
episode one racer's also arguably the
reason pod racing existed in
phantom menace at all it's not a movie
game you know it's it's a it's a game
that's inspired by an event in a movie
but it just takes you through some
interesting star wars worlds
it's a fun racing game they're raising
on military very fast very dangerous and
the nintendo switch version of the game
incorporates motion controls you can use
so again click the link below go to
aspire.com
star wars get your retro gaming on party
like it's 19.99
but in hd and thank you once again to
aspire for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it all right now
starting over all right now we talk
about one division complete with four by
three aspect ratio
black and white coloring and a laugh
track
right laugh tracks they make everything
funnier
you ever seen that the clip of friends
where it's ross without the laugh track
he's weird also spoiler alert i'm going
to talk about spoilers for the first two
episodes of juan division because that's
just
how i talk about tv shows i guess
spoiler running for the first two
episodes of one division you've been
warned so anyhow one division is a new
series it's on disney plus
stars wanda and vision yes the title
would entail
and it's executed like a mid-century
sitcom
it's just what we have to go on and i
feel like that's how i have to judge
it because that's all this show gives me
you know like
i know i mean we know some bullshit's
going on right you we know some [ __ ]
is going on because the mcu
isn't a mid-century sitcom but you don't
know why it's [ __ ] you know you're
like
is she in the good place is she in some
sort of snap purgatory
is is she in that episode of batman the
animated series where batman figured it
out because
all the words and books were all
scrambled around you don't know if she
knows it or not i know that
she can manipulate realities but nothing
in the mcu has ever shown me that
she could do that so hey maybe this is
the start of that you know comic books
and their comic book adaptations on
screen they're different you know like
because
she's magneto's daughter in the comic
books which could be now
now that they have the x-men which would
actually be really awkward
because quicksilver's her brother
quicksilver is also magneto's son
but the quicksilver that's magneto-sun
is not the same quicksilver that's her
brother
it's just anyhow it's beside the point
no no but you know something's
up you already know that because you're
already very familiar with the mcu which
is kind of working against
juan division because it's relying on
your attachment to the mcu to keep you
intrigued i know that because
if you're judging it based on these two
episodes if you're judging the show
based on just these two episodes it's
not that intriguing
actually not that clever as sitcom
either i mean i know it's a [ __ ]
sitcom it's like
a parody of a sitcom but it's not
executed that way it's executed
like a couple episodes of a sitcom
here's episode one of wandavision it's
wanda and vision's anniversary
wanda's planned a very romantic dinner
with vision
vision thinks he's supposed to bring his
boss and his boss's wife
over and they're gonna have a couple's
dinner wanda is very unprepared for that
so she has to prepare a meal
in the kitchen without them figuring out
that she wasn't prepared
all right and then here's episode two
vision eats a stick of gum which gums up
his inside so he acts all weird and
loopy and drunk the entire time but
while he is weird loopy drunk
and literally gummed up on the inside
they have to perform a magic trick in
front of the town
so shenanigans ensue like that's what it
is
that's that's all it is the point is the
show doesn't give you enough of that
intrigue to really hook you and keep you
going
for the rest of the show at least in the
first two episodes and it gives you a
couple of glimpses at the end of the
first episode
it's like it zooms out and there's a tv
where it's like the dr clavier was just
an arm with a remote
and someone's watching one division on
tv it
looks like the super evil layer kind of
looks like the bat cave to be honest
with you the arm of one of the turks
from final fantasy vii
is watching one division on tv like okay
that's weird there was just one thing in
the first episode it was at the very end
it's just this one quick
glimpse in the second episode you know
on the radio you hear some voice coming
through like
hello wanda who is doing this too and so
that's what you have also some beekeeper
looking dude crawls out of the sewer
and then time goes backwards and then
it's like it didn't happen but these are
very quick glimpses of things that's all
you have the other
58 minutes of these two episodes
put together because each episode is a
half hour long it's not that funny it's
not that interesting i would just much
rather prefer the intrigue being built
up by
interesting character interactions
interesting tension that's building is
just none of it really happens in the
first two episodes of one division
anyway
this is where i do understand why shows
release episodes week to week still in a
world where some shows just release
everything at once because it keeps the
internet talking you know if you look at
mandalorian people were talking about
mandalorian week to week the chatter
lasts a week
and then the next week rolls around
there's another episode and that chatter
lasts a week so
you get a lot more online chatter about
your show
youtube videos go up it feeds the
machine they get more out of it that way
i totally get it whereas you look at the
netflix formula
cobra kai people talk about it for a
week or two and then it's done but i
really think one division would benefit
by releasing all the episodes at once
it's like one division was filmed and
executed as a show where all the
episodes would go up at once so these
first two episodes that were
just a subpar sitcom that'd be fine
because you could binge the whole thing
so by the end of the day you have your
answers and the intrigue builds
throughout
so an hour of sitcoms that that's
it works and here i am in my head going
okay is the whole
mcu being a part of it working for it or
against it you know like i mean if you
showed a control group
these two episodes of wand division like
all right what do you think most people
would be like
why the [ __ ] do i care about this show
or the characters there are no
interesting interactions in there and
has an intriguing drama mystery twilight
zone-esque
thing that is executed like a sitcom
it's not that interesting but with the
mcu
backing it it's easy to be like yeah you
know
i'll give it a chance we'll see where it
goes it's not that i'm not
intrigued as to what's going on i am
but i am because i know the mcu
and i know this world isn't what the mcu
is so obviously something's [ __ ] here
but that's my knowledge of the mcu
making the show intriguing
not the execution of the show itself i
really think the setup which is these
first two episodes
just dragged on at first it was kind of
cool clever and different but then i'm
like okay let's
let's get on to actually getting to the
interesting part of this
weird twilight zone world but we never
got there was just some grade b
sitcom and i was like all right on to
the third episode next week i guess
i don't see a world where these two
episodes couldn't have been reconciled
into one episode as the show goes on and
starts coming into focus maybe it'll hit
the vibe of that twisted twilight zone
reality i
think they might be going for here but
for my money i i think they should have
hit that
in the first couple episodes that being
the first impression among people
watching the show
i don't know man i feel like a grumpy
deck i don't like being a grumpy dick so
i'm gonna go ahead and speed this
up we're gonna get to the end of this
one division the first two episodes have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more
click right here to see more
c